elle fait farfadets ou encore fait ces
personnages que l'on aime être de la
nature ou encore esprits de la nature
sont présents sur beaucoup de toiles de
l'artiste grataloup sur ce tableau c'est
l'esprit de l'air qui est dévoilée et
l'esprit de l'air et bien c'est ce
personnage qui est recouvert de feuilles
d'or 22 carats qui part finalement et
qui est libre qui sort de cette matière
qu'on voit sur la partie droite en bas
de la toile pour pour s'envoler vers
l'ère quoi et finalement ça c'est le
symbole en fête de la liberté profonde
de l'être humain qui choisit finalement
son destin l'exposition ciel et terre
est à découvrir au musée grataloup qui
va ouvrir ses portes samedi 12 mars
l'artiste décédé depuis peu avait choisi
l'emplacement de ces douze toiles qui
représente la relation de l'homme au
ciel finalement ça nous ramène à notre
humilité d'êtres humains et finalement
c'est ce qu'il s'était sa recherche en
fait métaphysique principalement et
finalement ça colle parfaitement au sens
profond de son travail cet autre tableau
fait partie de la série promesses d'aidé
m sur la thématique des fleurs et du yin
et du yang et vous voyez sur cette toile
ce qui est intéressant de voir à quel
point d'ailleurs grataloup était
quelqu'un et qui travaillait avec toutes
les techniques possibles et imaginables
et beaucoup de sable vous voyez sur la
partie droite toute la partie noire qui
comme de la sculpture c'est avec du
sable d'alcool
r on retrouve beaucoup beaucoup
l'utilisation du sable collé comme de la
sculpture dans ses toiles grands
coloristes grataloup travaillez beaucoup
avec l'or et le bleu cette exposition
est visible jusqu'au 30 septembre